hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor and today we're going to be
talking about heterocysts heterocysts
are how cyanobacteria enable their
nitrogen fixation process so let's talk
about what that is
so heterocysts are just these
specialized cells they're specialized in
terms of being able to fix nitrogen so
there are these nitrogen fixing cells
they're formed in filamentous
cyanobacteria this right here is
filamentous cyanobacteria
so basically individual bacteria that
grow kind of loosely connected in a
filament so in fill in to cyanobacteria
during periods of nitrogen starvation so
basically when they don't have enough
nitrogen in order to make the things
they need to be able to make some of the
cells will transition into heterocysts
in order to undergo nitrogen fixation
and get the nitrogen for the cell you
might be asking yourself what is
nitrogen fixation nitrogen fixation is
this metabolic process where atmospheric
nitrogen so just die nitrogen two
nitrogens connected together that's
what's in the atmosphere about 70% of
the air that we breathe is actually
nitrogen i'm at a lower percentage is
the oxygen that we need and so
atmospheric nitrogen if nitrogen in the
air and converting it to ammonia nh3 and
this is because ammonia is what they can
use to build various essential organic
molecules
and so what do we mean by organic
molecules we're talking about things
like DNA RNA proteins the DNA and RNA
are composed of nucleotides proteins are
made up of amino acids nucleotides and
amino acids both require nitrogen to
make the building blocks of those
essential organic molecules and so this
right here this formation of heterocysts
inside filamentous cyanobacteria is a
great example of what is known as
cooperation and when we refer to
cooperation between cells we mean that
they both do something and then share
with the other to their mutual benefit
so for example the heterocysts are
making the ammonia which is critical for
then making amino acids and nucleotides
and the other cells in the chain the
ones that are in green are
photosynthetic so they're taking the
energy from the Sun and storing it in
glucose and so the heterocysts and the
photosynthetic cells that are in the
same filament they benefit from each
other they they exchange or or share
metabolic products with each other and
that's what we call cooperation so again
this whole thing is filamentous
cyanobacteria each one of these is a
different cell and they are you know
individual bacterial cells but they are
physically connected and so they can
share with each other and they have this
strategy of compartmentalizing this this
kind of process and what I mean by that
is photosynthesis is happening in the
green ones nitrogen fixation is not a
nice event fixation is happening in the
purple one person that said this is not
and so this purple one right here and
this is the header assist when of course
is not purple in real life that's just
to distinguish it from the
photosynthetic cells drawn on the board
and so why is this compartmentalization
necessary why can't you just have every
cell fixing the nitrogen
NEADS and i'm conducting photosynthesis
why can't they all do both well it's
necessary because nitrogen fixation
relies on a specific enzyme is called
nitrogenase and nitrogenase is actually
inactivated by oxygen and of course
oxygen is one of the main products of
photosynthesis so if you have
photosynthesis occuring you can't have
nitrogen fixation occurring they can't
cover the same spaces because the
product of one keeps the other one from
being able to occur and so heterocysts
actually creates an environment that's
known as an an aerobic environment and
aerobic meaning no oxygen and they do
that three ways they actually make three
extra cell walls which are drawn here in
purple they degrade photosystem 2
photosystem two is one of the major
enzyme complexes that carries out
photosynthesis and they also produce
oxygen scavenging species which are
basically compounds proteins that
scavenge oxygen so find any residual
oxygen that may be left that may be left
from where the heterocysts was initially
formed and sequester it away or get rid
of it so they create this environment
where there's no more oxygen left in
here so nitrogenase can function and
then these cells are all sharing with
each other to keep the entire filament
alive so that is how cyanobacteria use
heterocysts to fix nitrogen that's
needed for all of these cells to survive
if you're interested in seeing any other
of my videos perhaps ones that will
introduce you to the concept of enzymes
they will further explain photosynthesis
since all respiration then check out my
videos on those topics and thank you for
watching biology professor